x-men spin off the new mutants is
finally coming out on august 28
2020 more than two years after it was
originally set to be released
these characters have been around for
decades and their actors have been
working for years but where exactly have
we seen these kids before
anya taylor joy's path to hollywood
began when she was flagged down by a
stranger in london at the age of 16
which sounds like the start of a horror
story the miami-born actor got quite the
shock when she noticed a mysterious
black car
started tailing her panicked to the
point that she picked up her dog and
started running
she later told style magazine that she
thought quote this is the end
so i like speed up pick up the dog and
then start running
and then this guy sticks his head out
the window and goes if you stop you
won't regret it
and i stopped it turned out not to be
the end but rather the beginning of
something huge
the person in the car was veteran
modeling agent sarah dukas
the woman who launched the careers of
kate moss and cara delevingne
taylor was signed to a contract the next
day and before long she was rubbing
elbows with acting agents too
taylor joy jumped in at the deep end
with her acting career taking on the
lead role in her first film
the newcomer was widely praised for her
performance as a puritan girl in 2015's
the witch
a new england set gothic horror that
blew the critics away
she cemented herself as an exciting new
talent the following year when she
appeared in sci-fi slasher morgan
college age barack obama biopic berry in
which she played the future president's
girlfriend
and m.9 shyamalan surprise superhero
sequel split
she would reprise the latter role in
2019's glass by which point her work on
the new mutants was already done and
dusted
fans of british drama will also
recognize taylor joy from her roles in
the miniaturist and peaky blinders
chances are you already know where
you've seen maisie williams before but
in case you've been living under a rock
this past decade she starred as arya
stark in the hbo fantasy series game of
thrones
williams's life was pretty much consumed
by game of thrones from the moment it
became a hit
with her mother choosing to pull her out
of school to concentrate on acting
full-time
but she still found time to work on
other projects during its eight season
run
she appeared in british shows like the
secret of prickly hall and doctor who
and she began making her mark in feature
films with lead roles in period mystery
piece
the falling in 2014 sci-fi thriller eye
boy in 2017
and adventure comedy then came you in
2018.
like his new mutants co-star maisie
williams charlie heaton rose to
prominence after landing a part in a tv
show that quickly blew up
he's portrayed jonathan byers on netflix
hit stranger things since the show's
first season though
unlike williams he had a number of
credits to his name prior to his big
breakthrough
he cut his teeth on british tv dramas
dci banks vera and casualty before
making the move to feature films in 2015
playing a drug dealer in the gangster
flick rise of the foot soldier part 2.
after a few more small roles in indie
films the yorkshire native was off to
hollywood
he had to rough it a little to begin
with but before long heaton was walking
red carpets
he told gq i had this crazy trajectory
i went from literally living in a hostel
in la at the beginning of 2015 to
shooting stranger things at the end of
2015.
i had this turbulent crazy year and then
the show came out in 2016.
he appeared alongside naomi watts and
psychological thriller shut-in that same
year
and in 2017 he filmed his scenes as
marvel mutant samuel guthrie
aka cannonball blue hunt wasn't very
well known when she landed the part of
mutant danielle moonstar
aka mirage but she wasn't exactly
plucked from obscurity either
han to his of lakota ancestry began
working on a web series when she moved
to la
she didn't have to wait long for her
first mainstream role in 2017 the cw
snapped her up to play a nadu a powerful
native american witch better known by
the name of the hollow and vampire
diaries spin off the originals which is
where you may know her from
hunt went straight into the new mutants
from there but she's played a number of
other roles since filming the x-men
movie
in 2019 hunt appeared in the debut
episode of colby smolder's crime drama
stump town which scored rave reviews
during its first season
she also went on to star in a lead role
on the netflix series another life
henry zaga made his debut in 2015 when
he appeared in an episode of the nbc
procedural the mysteries of laura
it was just a one-off appearance but he
was destined for bigger things anyway
soon after the up-and-comer landed the
role of josh diaz in teen wolf cementing
his spot among the ranks of hollywood's
newest teen heartthrobs
zaga made his feature film debut the
following year with a role in netflix's
xoxo
an ensemble film about the
interconnecting lives of six strangers
he popped up in former drug dealer angie
wong's debut feature
mdma in 2017 though that would be
largely overshadowed by his role in
another netflix production
he played tony's boyfriend brad in the
first season of 13 reasons why
like his new mutant's co-star zaga has
worked on numerous other projects since
he finished shooting the marvel film
seemingly happy to move from teen drama
to teen drama
he went on to play jake and hulu series
looking for alaska
and then portrayed luca in 13 episodes
of the netflix series trinkets
about three friends who meet at
shoplifters anonymous
unlike the youngsters under her supposed
care alice braga who plays dr
cecilia reyes has been around for some
time she made her film debut as angelica
in critical darling city of god and went
on to star in two more brazilian films
2005's lower city and 2006's only god
knows
before making the transition to
hollywood in the mid-2000s she became
known to wider audiences in 2007 when
she worked alongside will smith and i am
legend
playing the survivor who takes a cure
from the star before he blows himself
and a bunch of terribly rendered zombies
to pieces since then braga has split her
time between the states and brazil where
she has her own production company
she's never stopped acting however and
chances are you've seen her do her thing
on numerous occasions over the past
decade
even if he didn't know it in 2010 she
starred opposite jude law enforced
whitaker and action thriller repo men
and that same year she joined an
ensemble cast that included adrian brody
and lawrence fishburne for predators
an attempted revival of the sci-fi
franchise other notable credits include
the matt damon sci-fi thriller elysium
in 2013
and the simon pegg comedy kill me three
times the year after
since 2016 she starred on the hit show
queen of the south as theresa mendoza a
downtrodden mexican woman who builds a
drug empire
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]